hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seen and please
excuse my voluptuous hair today hi
I have dreadlocks or did I just ran out
of conditioner it's such a fun game so
tonight I am watching Back to the Future
for the first time
yep for the first time ever and unlike
the Jurassic Park Fiasco where I only
had seen the third episode or the third
movie a million times I just I've not
seen any of Back to the Future
none of them and they're gonna be so
many people who don't believe me that
I've not seen in every episode that I
put out there are people who are like
this is a lie like you're only doing
this to get views like you've definitely
seen these things how can you be a movie
reviewer not see these great movies and
first of all I'm not a movie reviewer
I'm just an actress on a movie review
show so there's that's that clears that
whole thing up and ya know I just I
haven't seen anything apparently
apparently I didn't have a childhood hi
mom hi dad thanks for watching but also
I always see people sprinkled in the
comment section who are like I've never
seen this either I thought it was the
only one so just everyone can you just
get off the back okay all right I'm
getting to it
I mean this is a really cool job I get
to watch these movies so I'm pretty sure
this is going to be more delightful than
the fly West but maybe not as impressive
or sexy so let just we'll have to see
here we go Oh Tanner has never seen that
was so good you guys are so good that
doesn't Ballou me out of the way blew me
out of the way I don't think that's a
phrase Tamra pretty sure it's blew me
away stop talking about blowing it was
like rabble I loved it so much I know I
say that about like 90% of the movies
that are talking
out on this here web series but I really
did I loved it I thought it was crazy
better than I thought it was gonna be
like you're laying on my notes bud I'm
just gonna slip this under yep well
there we go so the movie starts off and
Marty goes to Doc Brown's house but Doc
Brown isn't there so Marty decides to
play some music on his big-ass amp and
ruin everything in his apartment
honestly Marty ruins Doc Brown's
apartment like in the first five seconds
of the movie I have a giant fear of
getting into trouble and so I probably
just would have cried and then left and
then given up guitar forever take an
upset poetry or something but all of
this ruining happens and Marty's just
like rock and roll
is so cool it's not that cool I'm just
not that cool I love when Marty and his
band audition for battle of the bands at
their high school and they get the
typical 80s grown-up authoritative
response like oh you're much too loud
and you'll never amount to anything and
I'm a crabby old white guy Wow
I also love that he gets around town by
skateboarding and holding on to the back
of people's cars like he's already done
it like twice he's just he's so cool
guys he's so much cooler than me oh my
god Biff Biff can jump off a cliff
stupidest line in the world I gotta say
something
Biff sucks oh and then you see his
family Marty's family and they're so sad
they made their uncle a paroled cake and
then he didn't make parole so he
couldn't eat it so then you see the
DeLorean and it's such a cool reveal
with this hilarious and awesome vehicle
that they made into this time machine
and it's such a cool scene and then they
said I'm Stein into the future you guys
is it so great I just I love everything
about this scene I love all the
excitement I love that a dog is the
first time traveler I love that they're
in a JC Penney's parking lot testing
time truffle it's the best the DeLorean
was the perfect choice for the time
travel machine like I don't know there's
not many other cars that would have been
as perfect and weird of a chili just fit
so well like my first car was a 63 Dodge
Dart and it was awesome but it also
didn't go above 65 miles an hour and it
would stall on the freeway so wouldn't
it worked it didn't have seatbelts
though so they didn't need safety in the
60s so then the people that Doc Brown
got the plutonium from come up and start
shooting them and they're in a VW bus
which is also a car that I super really
want their car game is crushing it in
this movie and so they shoot Doc Brown
and Marty escapes in the DeLorean and
goes to the past and this is so stupid
because it's called Back to the Future
like you you need to get back to the
future but I've always seen like at
conventions and stuff like people have
like the future gear and and I'm
assuming that's going to be in the
second and third movie but for some
reason I just associated that with Back
to the Future so I was like oh why have
you go to the Past I went this will be a
short segment maybe and then they'll go
to the future but no they're just in the
past the whole time but it's awesome I
just was very confused and not
rightfully so
so Marty and Doc Brown make plans who
can get back to the future but first he
has to make sure that his mom and dad
fall in love so he doesn't disappear
from existence
hashtag highschool problem so Biff
basically says he's going to sexually
assault the Marty's mom and then she
calls his hands meat hooks
I'm gonna call everything that from now
on everything is now a meet him because
that is the most disgusting and
hilarious phrase I've ever heard in my
life
thank you showing so loud I hope that
picks up I hope you guys been here Ike
snoring hey little buddy
hey so one of my very favorite scenes in
the entire movie is when Marty goes to
his dad's house and dresses up like a
space alien named Darth Vader from the
planet Vulcan such a good reference yes
yes yes thank you all right yeah that's
hard I could fix ah so the whole Marty
Biff chasing where Biff scar gets filled
with manure is incredible he's so he's
so cool II who could no wonder his mom
is in love with him I'm usually not into
clean-shaven guys just a personal
preference but Marty McFly can get it oh
god he kisses his mom that's done call
it off then Biff legitimately tries to
rape Marty's mother and it's terrible
and don't like that scene at all but
George
Marty's dad comes in and saves her and
it's really nice that's good thank God
and then they fall in love and the dance
is a success and the soundtrack of this
movie is so good like it's sneaky good
like until this moment I was like huh oh
it's been excellent so far I didn't even
realize that like it gets in the way of
nothing it's so good I had to change the
battery so the shot might be different
sorry about that or not if it's not
maybe it looks exactly
the steam leading up to him going back
to the future is incredible and super
suspenseful and really touching with the
moments between him and Doc Brown just
because he thinks that Doc Brown isn't
going to be alive when he gets back and
it's so great and then he makes it and
it's literally one of the best movie
moments I've ever experienced like I was
giggling and it was so much fun and oh
this is such a good movie oh the bullet
fest and he saved the letter it's so
good and then it just keeps getting
better after that his family isn't
depressing anymore they're all really
wonderful and happy and there's no
parole cakes anywhere also Biff gets
what he deserves
I don't wish anyone a sad life but
you're trying to rape girls yeah and
then I just I thought it was just gonna
end like that but doc who keep wanting
to say doc Martin which is my favorite
shoe brand right it's a dog Brown okay
um then Doug Brown comes back from the
future and is like we gotta go and
Marty's like no I'm going on a trip with
my girlfriend and he's like bring her to
because it has to do with your kids what
yes also I really admire all these high
school relationships in this movie that
stand the test of time and lead to
children it's not realistic but it's
nice it's like almost a perfect movie I
feel like I don't know I know I'm Way
behind I know all of you are like yeah
Tamra get with the fucking times but God
dang it was so good like all these
movies that I'm watching for this I'm
enjoying them um but this one held up so
so incredibly well like just as good as
Jurassic Park did I didn't enjoy the
kind of sexist themes in the 50s but I
mean they were in the 50s so I guess
that's a good
I don't know that was kind of weird I
just don't enjoy watching that kind of
stuff and I understand it had a purpose
in the movie but yeah that was the movie
and now I know what I'm gonna do for the
next two weeks thanks for watching these
videos if we just explaining videos that
you've seen I'm Tamra and do you want to
get in this this episode but this is Ike
I'm holding him like a child
okay I'm sorry it's not very nice he
doesn't like that alright bye guys see
you next week